hi guys I'm a lot of Cheryl on Azad and
today you are watching a 2015
collectibles update where I'm gonna be
showing you all of the collectibles that
I have gotten up until the stop 2015
because I didn't have time to do a full
gaming room to us so let's go stunning
up the tawny tiger full collector's
edition statue it's really a really big
and fairly good quality but
unfortunately this guy has gotten a
little lean on so it's not the best it
does also light up this is my beloved
Brotherhood of Steel helmet
it's totally wearable padded on the
inside and quite comfortable there's a
separate video about that on my channel
if you'd like to see remote control
Yoshi
he's pretty cute and a giant Commander
Shepard so these are all basically
things that wouldn't fit in shelves so
then we're gonna start on the Left
cabinet here this is a one of my Marvel
shows we have cable Iron Man and Iron
Man hand Deadpool kiya and venom so
cable unfortunately his gun came off
while I was moving house same with Iron
Man's finger up the back there we got
both of them fixed and this one this
venom here actually shattered completely
when I put it on the Shelf that just
fell off but someone anonymously I still
don't know who it was sent a brand new
one to my PA books so that one is easily
my most prized collectible someone just
out of the kindness of their heart sent
me anyone and I just kind of can't even
believe that that happened it's
absolutely amazing
this is Marvel's shelf number two we've
got century off the back there who I
actually like despite most people not
liking him a little Wolverine here
another venom and an Iron Man of the
backpacker was also sent by a fan so my
mobile shelves are two of my most
expensive shelves and probably have the
most limited edition or collectors items
of any of my shelves this one here is
kind of a miscellaneous anime show we've
got some of my new yo stuff over here if
that said of Cairo particularly really
love a neighbor up the back there we've
got strike freedom gundam some Death
Note characters and not a little over
there and of course Full Metal Alchemist
well my first cabinet is eight years of
war shelf I'm actually missing the
medallion from from that which is part
of the Gears of War 3 collector's
edition it's just in my bedroom a custom
control that I got built that actually
doesn't work very well but I figured
kind of fit this shelf with the blood
splatter
super limited edition snub pistol was
one of six in Australia when they were
originally sold and Marcus Fenix from
the Gears of War 3 collector's edition
at the top of shelf number 2 is my
Batman shelf definitely one of my
favorites this is the Dark Knight Rises
collector's edition Cal it's broken
Batman cowl which I just thought was
particularly cool got a Batarang there
that's one of 250 Arkham City
collector's edition batman arkham
origins collector's edition batman and
this is one of the arkham asylum figures
back there I kind of just wedged him in
the middle there to make it kind of look
like he's floating so maybe he's you
know grappling up somewhere and then my
favorite on the Shelf is definitely that
right there which is nightmare Batman
this here is my Ubisoft shark which
really just features a lot of Assassin's
Creed from back when I really loved the
franchise of course we've got Ezio Ezio
Ezio it's the old side yeah and hate
them because I particularly liked him as
a spy glass from a c4 and a little drink
from a c4 as well and then of course we
got fast Montenegro and we've got
Cartman from the stick of truth one more
down here and another of my absolute
favorite shows obviously really just a
lot of Goku's I really like oh can you
guys but I've also got these bad boys
here piccolo kind of thrusting after
more Quigley sans Scouter and we've got
all of the Dragon Balls and ready to
make a wish this down here is my
Nintendo shelf and definitely my least
impressive shelf definitely got to build
on this but this little guy right here
this Psyduck was technically the first
ever collectible that I ever had my mum
bought it for me ages ago he takes
battery and squeaks and waddles so I
think I probably got him I don't know
before I can even remember he's still in
working conditions so that's where it
all started I guess but then we've got
Mario is actually a das hallo but none
of my dears is fit unfortunately so he's
holding him you and Yoshi and xerneas
this one is falling over and always
falls over which is horrible and that's
a remote control Bowser as well we're
now at the top of a shelf number 3 as
you can see so this is my V seek help
obviously and who's just over there so
we've got a bunch of jokers just here I
love that Killing Joke Joker definitely
one of my favorites Deathstroke there
he's a new and beautiful Greenland
scarecrow flash and this is from the
injustice gods among us collector's
edition unfortunately that's Joker this
one just here
takes up so much space that it really
has thrown this shelf off because he's
along with the TVs all behind him that
was another Arkham origins collector's
edition and I think that I may just have
to get rid of him one day because I hate
how much space he takes up this is a
miscellaneous videogame shelf that I
kind of just sort of tried to
color-coordinate a little bit we've got
death from Darkseid is to his mascot
there we've got war from Darksiders Alex
Mercer
we've got Eve from Bioshock a Big Daddy
and we've got all the way and of course
and then the only thing that I just kind
of doesn't fit in here really as little
as a dame they're from Final Fantasy 9
this is another miscellaneous videogame
shelf and then we have Johnny dark there
from Perfect Dark one of the rarest
things that I own for sure a yarny there
who is definitely one of my favourite
female video game characters Nathan
Drake we've got a little vanquish guy
down there who doesn't stand up very
well at all some minecraft halo stuff
and then we've got my nice little
collection of for that stuff there and
another absolute favorite shelf here
this is my Legend of Zelda shelf
we've got darunia up there who I bought
for myself as a 21st present I love him
have wanted him forever and so happy to
finally have him we've got Ganon there
winwaker down and again there who lives
in a little bubble we've got heileen
show with some swords and of course we
have a link I've also got a small
collection of swords over here though a
lot of them are still in my bedroom at
the moment and not actually in here
media passes from the past three years
and then we have video games lots and
lots of video games